welcome to level one linear equations
so let's start doing some problems so
let's say i had the equation
five
that's a big fat five five x
equals twenty so at first this might
look a little unfamiliar for you but if
i were to rephrase this i think you'll
realize this is a pretty easy problem
all this is this is the same thing as
saying
five
times
question mark
equals 20.
and the reason why we do the notation a
little bit we write the 5 next to the x
because when you write a number right
next to a variable you assume that
you're multiplying them so this is just
saying 5
times x so instead of a question mark
we're writing an x so 5 times x is equal
to 20.
now most of y'all could do that in your
head you could say well what number
times 5 is equal to 20 well
it equals 4. but i'll show you a way to
do it systematically just in case that 5
was a more complicated number
so let me make this a little my pen a
little thinner okay
so rewriting it if i had 5 x
equals
20. we could do two things and they're
essentially the same thing we could say
we just divide both sides of this
equation by five
in which case the left-hand side those
two fives will cancel out we'll get x
and the right hand side 20 divided by 5
is 4. and we would have solved it
another way to do it and this is
actually the exact same way we're just
phrasing a little different if you said
5x
equals 20
instead of dividing by five we could
multiply by one-fifth
and if you look at that you can realize
that multiplying by one-fifth is the
same thing as as dividing by five if you
know the difference between dividing and
multiplying fractions
and then that gets the same thing one
fifth times five is one so you're just
left with an x
equals
four
i tend to focus a little bit more on
this because when we start having
fractions instead of a five it's easier
to just think about multiplying by the
reciprocal
actually let's do one of those right now
so let's say i had
negative
three
over four
times
x
equals to equals
over 13.
now this is a harder problem i can't do
this one in my head we're saying
negative 3 4 times some number x
is equal to 10 over 13. if someone came
up to you on the street and asked you
that i i think you'd be like me and
you'd be
pretty uh stumped but let's let's work
it out algebraically well we do the same
thing
we multiply both sides by the
coefficient on x so the coefficient all
that is all that fancy word means is the
number that's being multiplied by x so
what's the co what's the reciprocal of
minus three-fourths well it's
minus four
over three
times and
dot is another way to use times and
you're probably wondering why in algebra
um
there are all these other conventions
for doing times as opposed to just a
traditional multiplication sign and the
main reason is i think just a regular
multiplication sign gets confused with
the variable x so they thought of either
using a dot if you're multiplying two
constants or just writing it next to a
variable to imply you're multiplying a
variable
so if we multiply the left hand side by
negative four thirds we also have to do
the same thing
to the right hand side
minus four thirds the left-hand side the
minus four-thirds and the three-fourths
they cancel out you could work it out on
your own to see that they do they equal
one so we're just left with x is equal
to
ten times minus four is minus forty
thirteen times three well that's equal
to 39
so we get x is equal to minus 40 over 39
and i like to leave my fractions
improper because it's easier to
to deal with them but you could just you
could also view that if that's minus
if you want to write it as a mixed
number minus 1 and 139
i tend to keep it like this though
let's check to make sure that's right
the cool thing about algebra is you can
always get your answer and put it back
into the original equation and make sure
you're right so the original equation
was
minus
3 4
times x and here we'll substitute the x
back into the equation where we wherever
we saw x we'll now put our answer
so it's minus
40 over 39
and our original equation said that that
equals 10 over 13.
well and once again when i just write
the three-fourths times the pres right
next to the parentheses like that that's
just another way of writing times
so
minus 3 times minus 40
is
minus
100 and actually we could we could do
something a little bit simpler this 4
becomes a 1 and this becomes a 10.
and if you remember how when you're
multiplying fractions you can
simplify it like that so it actually
becomes minus actually plus 30 because
we have a minus times a minus and 3
times 10
over the 4 is now 1 so all we have is
left is 39
and 30 over 39 if we divide the top and
the bottom by three
we get
10 over 13
which is the same thing as what the
equation said it we would get so we know
that we got the right answer
let's do one more problem
minus
x
is equal to 7 8. if you want to try this
problem yourself now's a good time to
pause
and i'm going to start doing the problem
right now
so same thing what's the reciprocal of
minus 5 6 well it's
minus 6 over 5.
we multiply that if you do it on the
left hand side we have to do it on the
right hand side as well
minus six over five the left-hand side
the minus six over five and the minus
five six cancel out we're just left with
x
and the right-hand side
we have well we can take the the the we
could divide both the six and the eight
by two so this becomes negative three
this becomes four
seven times negative three is minus 21
over 20.
and assuming i haven't made any careless
mistakes that should be right actually
let's just check that real fast
so minus 5 6
times minus 21 over 20.
well
that equals
this 5. we could make that at a 1. turn
this into a 4.
make this into a 2 make this into a 7.
negative times negative is positive so
you have 7
two times four is eight and that's what
we said we would get
so we got it right
i think you're you're ready at this
point to try some level one equations uh
have fun